now I said I'll show you an easy method
writing this works some of the time I
need to show you the trickier method as
well because this easy method it
requires you to have a nice easy like
all these numbers are really easy to
look at right the ones are the ones and
the force and the force it's a simple
diagram but sometimes you don't get a
simple diagram so the trickier method is
you need two points okay let me show you
what I mean okay instead of taking you
know drawing a triangle on there okay I
want you to pick any two points any two
points that are on that line okay pick
one for me pick one for me three like x
equals three
okay so if I put that three now what I
want you to do is I want you look at
your diagram right and use the grid and
that three will go up to here and it'll
go to some Y value okay now can you tell
me what the Y value is it should be 4
right good so tell me what are the
coordinates at that point it's going to
be 3 the X comes first
for that point there 3 4 ok great
so here's my first point 3 4
I've got one point give me another one
ok sure if I put in if I went over here
five right I go all the way up and like
you said I'll be there
five six okay so here's my other point
okay now I want to work out granny
grannys the hardest part okay so it
looks like this I'm going to show you a
weird awkward equation right formula if
you like but it's very very useful okay
I want rise over
now remember we got four here before
where did that fall come from how did
you work that out when we run we did the
horizontal pot and that was kind of easy
because it's just zero to four right but
the rise was trickier how did you get
for this ah good yeah one to five or
another way of saying that is it was
five minus one that's how you get the
full okay so that rise is it's one of
the y-values I want to call it Y two
minus the other Y value okay that's what
I did this Y value five my is this way
about one okay and that told me how far
away the runs exactly the same except
runs about horizontal instead of up down
right so it's gonna be the X values okay
so I know that looks a bit awkward but
let me show you and like I said it's
trickier but let me show you how it
works okay mmm you gave me two points
okay it had an x and a y okay and then
this one also had an X and a one okay
and in fact I label them like that and
if you've got another color it's super
useful okay so here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take this formula and I'm
gonna use all of these pieces right
let's see them fit together watch why
don't you minus y1 which number of our
label white wait hold on
it's xmn why write these two six right
six what's the other way value it'll be
for good six minus four okay that's
gonna be the rise I just now divide it
okay what are my X values x 2 which is 5
and then I've got X 1 which is 3
okay 6 minus 4 is
- five - three years also - and there's
the one that you expected from before
cuz you already done this question now
like I said you're like wow that's work
like look at the letters and the algebra
and that should I just draw a triangle
well well you use the a easy method
where you can write when it's a nice
simple diagram all of these everything's
like whole numbers and stuff on this
diagram so it's great for a triangle but
sometimes you'll get something that's
gross and you can't like it doesn't it
doesn't match up to a nice easy point a
whole number okay so then you have to
take this approach which is using two
points okay